bienvenidos a el vídeo de restas básicas
lo que haremos en este vídeo es empezar
con un poco de práctica
respecto a las sumas así es que veamos
cuánto será 4 + 3 digamos que tengo 4
limones 1 2 3 4 con los que pensaba
hacer una limonada un agua y ustedes
llegan y me regalan tres limones
esto ya lo hemos visto en las más
básicas tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 es igual a
7 si de cualquier manera lo hacemos en
la línea de los números pongamos aquí el
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y veamos si realmente
nuestra operación fue real empezamos en
el 4 y ese 4 le sumaremos le añadiremos
1 2 3 llegamos al 7 esto ustedes ya lo
conocen perfectamente de los vídeos
anteriores sin embargo ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es restar esto es sumar
sumar
como se aplica en las restas
cuántos eran
4 - 3
ok veamos el mismo ejemplo de los
limones tengo originalmente mis 4
limones
pero ahora le quitaré restar tres
limones esto implica que yo les voy a
dar tres limones a ustedes de los cuatro
que yo tenía voy a darles tres a ustedes
no sé tal vez se compraron unos tacos y
le quieren echar limones voy a quitar
uno dos tres estoy restando estoy
eliminando o quitando eso es restar así
es que vuelvo a contar y solo me quedo
14 menos 3 y a 4 limones le quito 3 es
igual a 1 que es únicamente este que
quedo aquí
cómo se ve esto en la línea de números
volvamos a hacer nuestra línea aquí
y contemos 0 1 2 3 4 5
789 recuerden que esta flecha indica que
el número puede ser tan grande como
nosotros nos imaginemos
pueden imaginarse el número más grande
más grande del mundo y aún así pueden
sumarle uno entonces esta flecha indica
que esos números son enormes y que se
puede ir hasta el infinito
ahora hagamos este ejercicio aquí
empezamos en 4
y quitaremos tres recuerdan como en la
línea de la suma vamos hacia la derecha
porque estamos añadiendo lo estamos
incrementando
en la en la línea de los números hoy me
trabo me trago me pongo nerviosa con
esto de las restas en la línea de las
restas lo que haremos es ir hacia la
izquierda
porque estaremos incrementando o
quitando en este caso empezaremos en el
4 menos 3
nos vamos hacia la izquierda 123 y
volvemos a llegar al número 1
lo ven
vamos a poner esto un poco más
interesante en la suma siempre tienes
más incrementas en la resta tienes menos
cómo se manejaría esto
de tal manera que 4
vamos a ponerle un color más interesante
4 - 14 menos 1 volvamos a hacer el
ejercicio de los limones
1 2 3 4 y esta vez solo quitaré 1
o digamos que son manzanas vamos a
cambiar los limones por manzanas
esta es una manzana roja
dos manzanas rojas tres manzanas rojas
cuatro manzanas rojas si estas cuatro
manzanas yo me como una
haremos lo mismo que con los limones
eliminamos solo una me la comí
desapareció o se la regalé a mi maestra
en la primaria
esto significa que tenemos 1 2 3
tiene sentido y si lo hacemos en nuestra
línea ahora tomaremos el color verde y
empezaremos en el 4
y a 4 le quitaremos 1 recuerda nos vamos
hacia la izquierda porque estamos
restando empezamos en el 4 y le quitamos
y llegamos a este mismo número 3 aquí
hay algo interesante que hemos visto en
la suma es recuerdan nosotros ya
sabíamos que tres más uno es igual a
cuatro y eso ya no lo sabemos porque lo
conocemos de memoria y lo hemos
practicado una y otra vez de la misma
manera que aprendimos que 1 + 3 es igual
a 4 es decir cuando nosotros cambiamos
el orden de cualquier manera nos dará 4
porque estoy manejando esto porque si
nos damos cuenta 4 menos 1 es igual a 3
que de hecho significa que sea 4 sea 4
manzanas yo le quito una me va a dar 3 o
lo mismo que si tengo 3 manzanas y le
sumo una oleada una voy a tener 4 esto
lo verán más adelante en álgebra espero
no estamos confundiendo pero ya lo verán
más adelante lo que sí podemos hacer en
este momento para evitar eso es en el
próximo vídeo haremos cuantas
operaciones básicas podamos hacer en un
periodo de 8 a 10 minutos para que
ustedes vayan teniendo esta idea y poco
a poco dominen un poco más esto así como
con las sumas recuerdan tomamos práctica
para poderlo aprender y manejarlo con la
facilidad que hoy lo hacen haremos lo
mismo con las restas manejaremos esto de
tal manera que practicaremos y
practicaremos y practicaremos hasta que
puedan tener estos números en la cabeza
los aprendamos y podamos hacer las
operaciones de una manera mucho más
sencilla nos vemos en el próximo vídeo